Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En 1984, dos trabajadores
descubrieron un cuerpo
en un pantano en las afueras
de Cheshire, Inglaterra.
Los oficiales llamaron
al cuerpo el Hombre de Lindow
y determinaron que había
sufrido serias heridas
que incluían un traumatismo
fuerte y estrangulación.
Pero lo más impactante
de toda esta macabra historia
fue que pudieron determinar todo eso de
un cuerpo de más 2000 años de antigüedad.
Lo común es que la descomposición
hace difícil detectar dichas heridas
en un cuerpo enterrado por unas semanas.
¿Entonces cómo es que este cadáver
se conservó tan perfectamente?
¿Y por qué no todos los cuerpos
se mantienen en esta condición?
Las respuestas a estas preguntas
yacen casi dos metros bajo tierra.
No parece haber mucha vida aquí,
pero una cucharadita de tierra
contiene más organismos
que seres humanos en el planeta.
Desde bacteria y algas
hasta hongos y protozoos,
la tierra es el hogar de una cuarta parte
de la biodiversidad de la Tierra.
Y quizá los habitantes más importantes
de la tierra son los microbios,
organismos no más grandes
que varios cientos de nanómetros
que descomponen todo el material
orgánico muerto y moribundo.
Imagina que dejas caer
una manzana en el bosque.
Tan pronto toca la tierra,
los gusanos y otros invertebrados
comienzan a romperlo en pedacitos,
absorbiendo nutrientes de lo
que consumen y excretan el resto.
Esta primera etapa de la descomposición
pone la escena para los microbios.
Los microbios específicos
presentes según el ambiente.
Por ejemplo, en pastizales y campos
de cultivo tiende a haber más bacteria,
que son buenos en romper pastos y hojas.
Pero en estos bosques templados
hay más hongos,
capaces de romper
materiales leñosos complejos.
Para cosechar más alimento
de los restos de la manzana,
los microbios liberan enzimas
que activan una reacción química
llamada oxidación.
Ésta rompe las moléculas de
la materia orgánica, libera energía,
carbón y otros nutrientes en
un proceso llamado mineralización.
Luego, estos microbios consumen
carbón y algunos nutrientes,
mientras que moléculas excedentes
de nitrógeno, sulfuro, calcio y otros
se quedan en la tierra.
Conforme los insectos y gusanos
comen más de la manzana,
exponen más área superficial
para que estas enzimas microbianas
oxiden y mineralicen.
Incluso las excreciones que dejan
son minadas por los microbios.
Esto continua hasta
que la manzana se reduce a nada,
un proceso que tomaría de uno
a dos meses en un bosque templado.
Ambientes calientes y húmedos
sustentan a más microbios
que aquellos lugares fríos y secos,
lo que les permite
descomponer cosas más rápido.
Y los materiales orgánicos menos complejos
se rompen más rápido.
Pero con el tiempo suficiente,
toda la materia orgánica se reduce a
nutrientes minerales microscópicos.
Los enlaces atómicos
entre estas moléculas
son demasiado fuertes para romperse más.
Es así que estos nutrientes
alimentan la vida vegetal,
lo que crea más alimento
que con el tiempo se descompondrá.
Este ciclo constante de
creación y descomposición
sustenta toda la vida en la Tierra.
Pero hay unos pocos
ambientes demasiado hostiles
para estos multitalentosos microbios,
como son los pantanos
a las afueras de Cheshire, Inglaterra.
Los pantanos se componen principalmente
de musgo de turbera altamente ácido.
Estas plantas acidifican la tierra
mientras que liberan un compuesto
que enlaza al nitrógeno,
privando al área de nutrientes.
Aunado a las frías temperaturas
del norte de Europa,
estas condiciones hacen imposible
que los microbios funcionen.
Sin nada que pueda descomponerlo,
el musgo muerto se apila,
evitando que el oxígeno entre al pantano.
El resultado es un sistema
naturalmente sellado.
Cualquier materia orgánica
que entre al pantano se queda ahí,
como el Hombre de Lindow.
El ácido del pantano fue
lo suficientemente fuerte
para disolver material relativamente
simple como el hueso,
y ennegrecer tejido más complejo
como la piel y los órganos.
Pero el cadáver quedó
tal bien conservado
que se pudo determinar
que tuvo salud, tenía veintitantos
y potencialmente acomodado pues su cuerpo
tenía pocas señales de trabajo pesado.
Incluso se sabe de la última comida
del hombre de Lindow,
un pedazo de pan quemado por digerir.
Los investigadores tienen menos certeza
de las circunstancia de su muerte.
Mientras que un asesinato
a sangre fría es una posibilidad,
la severidad de sus heridas
sugiere un sacrificio ritual.
Incluso de hace 2000 años,
hay evidencia de
que el pantano se conocía
por sus cualidades casi supernaturales;
un lugar en el que la tierra debajo
de los pies no estaba ni muerta ni viva.